[موسيقى]
في دلهي الآن ،
أنت لست بعيدًا عن حسرة القلب ،
فقد تمت زيارة كل شخص في هذه المدينة تقريبًا
بسبب الحزن
في محرقة الجثث في السيمابوري ، فالخسارة لها
وزن كبير في الهواء المحترق
والموتى
يتراكمون هناك جثثًا في كل مكان
تلتفت إليه هنا.  بصراحة لم يروا
شيئًا مثله تمامًا
ويقول المنظمون
إنهم قد يحرقون
سبعة أو ثمانية أشخاص يوميًا لوحدهم اليوم
، لقد أحرقوا بالفعل 55 جثة
ولم يحن حتى وقت الغداء
قبل شهور حتى تفاخرت قيادة الهند
بأن البلاد كانت فعالة
هزمت كوفيد
الآن ، فقد سجلت أرقامًا قياسية عالمية للحالات الجديدة
حيث أن الموجة الثانية المرعبة تدمر
البلد الذي
قال عنه رجل الجو سينغ شنتي إنه
ورجاله لا يتوقفون
حتى لأخذ فترات راحة وما زالوا بالكاد يستطيعون
التعامل مع التدفق
الذي يقترب منه المتطوعون.  نفد
من الطاولات للجثث كما يقول
ثم يضيف أن والدته ماتت من
مرض كوفيد -19 في الليلة التي سبقت
لك يجب أن تكون متعبًا تقلق
ولكن الوقت هو ملاحظة بالنسبة
للباقي افعل ذلك  أنت تعتقد أن الحكومة
تحسب عدد
القتلى بالأرقام المرغوبة التي تقدمها أم
أنك تعتقد أن الأرقام الحقيقية
أعلى بكثير من الأرقام التي تراها على
التلفزيون هي عدد الأشخاص
الذين يموتون
في المستشفيات التي يقول إنهم  عدم
احتساب الأشخاص الذين ماتوا في المنزل
بمعزل عن غيرهم إذا تمت إضافة هذه الأرقام ،
سيرتفع العدد الفعلي ثلاث
مرات
لمواكبة تلك الأرقام المتزايدة
، حيث أُجبرت محرقة الجثث على
التوسع ،
مما أدى إلى إنشاء منطقة فائض في
موقف سيارات مجاور
شيام شارما  يودع
أخيه الأصغر البالغ من العمر 45 عامًا
الليلة الماضية ، كنت أفكر في أن
صحته تتحسن
ولكن فجأة جاء هاتف الطبيب
على هاتفي المحمول الذي انتهت صلاحية أخيك ،
هل تعتقد أنه كان من
الممكن منع وفاته ،
نعم نعم نعم أعتقد  يمكنه أن يقول
أنه يمكننا إنقاذه من
خلال مستشفى صحي أفضل
نظام الرعاية الصحية في الهند على حافة
الانهيار
غير قادر على التعامل مع حجم
الأزمة
التي تركها الناس  يدبروا لأنفسهم ، كان
هذا الحشد ينتظر لمدة ست
ساعات
للحصول على فرصة للحصول على بعض الأكسجين الذي
لا يمكنهم الاعتماد على الحالة
هل تحتاج إلى أكسجين
[موسيقى]
هي حالة حرجة للغاية من الأكسجين لديها
[موسيقى
] ونحن نحاول منذ الصباح  نحن
لا نتعرض للسموم ، كم عدد الأماكن
التي ذهبت إليها في
19 منذ الصباح منذ الساعة 6 صباحًا.
هل حاولت نقلها إلى
المستشفى ، لا توجد أسرة ،
لا توجد أسرة قبل أربعة أيام ،
لقد حاولنا كثيرًا ولكننا لم نحاول
[موسيقى  ]
كنت محظوظًا بما يكفي للعثور على والدتها في
مكان في المستشفى
فقط لتكتشف أنه لا يوجد أكسجين في
حوالي
10 أيام ، لقد رأيت أمام عيني
ما يجب أن أفعله وأنا خائفة جدًا
مما سيحدث مع أمي
أنت  أنا غاضب للغاية بسبب
هذه المنظمة ، إن
حكومتنا مهملة للغاية لدرجة
أنهم لا
يهتمون بما يعانيه الجمهور ، فهم
لا يعرفون
من أي شيء نعاني منه ،
وهناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين يقفون من
أجله ويقاتلون  لهذا الشيء
والدتها ن  في حالة حرجة
مثل الكثيرين هنا ، تشعر
بالإرهاق
التام لأولئك الذين لا يستطيعون الحصول على الأكسجين الخاص بهم ،
هذا
هو الخيار الوحيد
لمركز الأكسجين بالسيارة على جانب الطريق
، تصل امرأة فاقدًا للوعي في
عربة يد قامت
العديد من المستشفيات بالفعل بتشغيلها
بعيدًا
، لم يكن لديهم الأسرة
الآن ، فهي تعتمد على لطف
الغرباء ، حيث
يعمل الأبناء يائسًا لمحاولة إحيائها ،
فهذه ليست مستشفى أو حتى عيادة ،
إنها معبد للسيخ ولكن بالنسبة لهؤلاء الأشخاص
الذين كانوا بالفعل  ابتعدوا عن
العديد من المستشفيات ،
فهذه هي فرصتهم الأخيرة للبقاء على قيد
الحياة ، يقول زعيم جمعية السيخ الخيرية التي تدير
هذا المرفق
إنها لا تحصل على أي دعم على الإطلاق من
الحكومة
التي يقول إنه كان يطمع بها بالفعل مرتين ،
لكنه ومتطوعوه يواصلون
العمل
24 ساعة  في يوم نريد إنقاذ
حياتهم ،
هذا صوت قلبنا ، يجب أن يؤذي
قلبك
لرؤية الطريقة التي يعاني بها شعبك ،
نعم يا رجل ،
نبكي عدة مرات ، كما
أنه من المستحيل أن يحدث ما يحدث.  إن مأساة
الموجة الثانية من فيروس كورونا المستجد
تعصف بكبار السن ،
لكنها لم تسلم من شباب الهند ،
فقد أعلن رئيس الوزراء أن
كل شخص يزيد عمره عن 18 عامًا
يمكنه الحصول على اللقاح ولكن مع تلقيح أقل من
2 في المائة من البلاد
لا يقدم سوى  أمل بعيد
حتى تستمر عاصمة الهند في الاحتراق
بسبب انتشار هذا
الفيروس
القاتل ، مدينة ودولة جثو على ركبتيها
للصلاة من أجل استراحة
كلاريسا عنبر سي إن إن نيو دلهي